so this is so funny my sister just
texted me and she was like justine there
is this contest going on to be vanna
white for a day and she's like you have
to enter so i quickly threw on a fancy
dress and um i made my submission video
here so
i just thought it'd be funny to post it
on youtube because if i didn't probably
no one would ever see it and since the
contest entry deadline is like
right now and they probably already
picked their finalists either way i just
thought it was really funny and i
thought that i would share with you guys
um yeah does anybody else watch wheel of
fortune because
it's my sister's
favorite show ever and i know they've
auditioned a couple of times and they
never made it but anyway either way this
is my video
it's so cheesy
all right peace out how to be vanna
white for a day it's my dream and you
guys can make my dream a reality i mean
just look at these skills that i have of
walking in heels
yeah
and you know what else
can you do this in heels
[Music]
and please take note of my amazing
presentation skills for this bean bag
years and years of training to get to
that point ladies and gentlemen and if
that's not enough watch this
professional professional
and another thing too that is key to
being vanna white is fancy dresses and
i've got a lot of fancy dresses shiny
fancy
dresses fancy fancy dresses fancy
fancy i can even find some fancy pants
if you want the wheel of fortune just
can't handle me right now the wheel of
fortune just can't handle me right now
the wheel of fortune just can't handle
me right now
[Music]
you